you have to water squad  okay work what rows one for teams and  each team on earth  first thing  you have to  and they would say that with one team  otherwise if you have friends if you  need to like hide it  you don't want to give it away teletraan  Seema / Allah and a sugar mono okay wait  a shoe gamma I know  the sentence is the check you know there  is mica icon yes  next sentences from English great be  sure to discuss terms with the chalk  just I need help please  okay yes that is awesome  Oh  me junctional please cut out a caption  on even the city carols which is plural  liquor out there then the subjects  Laurel the verb is caption or not yeah a  caption is B to C and then in hi and so  we said that patina and for mother only  one so they want this challenge  member